hi
i'm standing i'm standing
i'm still standing are we lying so okay
here we go
richie no it's not like elton john yes
but it's also
from the cartoon sink someone from there
i'm still standing
still finish it let us know we're live
we are live
we're officially live episode number 74.
are we live or no
okay we are live episode 74 with tom and
adam
and we took a break last thursday is
that the time i was in the robot but
it's good to be back
it's good to be around everybody you
look good yeah we had a good time it was
a
casual tuesday for you today yes i
intentionally wanted to make you guys
look good because that's called
leadership i wanted you to look good
with your
new white shirt that you got on it's a
it's is it a tom ford or is it a tom
chevy
that's the direction he's going for by
the way
we have a lot of stories today a lot of
stories first of all conor mcgregor
versus uh podium which was a
very very interesting fight we'll have
to cover that and yeah i have to tell
you a story about the best card of
counter i just bought it's a psa 10
gem mint show that and autograph 10 it
says rookie card i don't know if you
guys can see it or not and zoom in on it
if you can
yeah that's his card and uh i'm
i'm still in the mindset of buying hold
with connor i think connor's got a big
can you see it or no did you go on it
when i saw it i didn't even recognize
him because he actually looks like a
fighter there yeah yeah he does he today
he looks like a billionaire it's
a different look he's got when you say
buy and hold you still think what you're
about to say you still think he's got
this guy's upside the only thing i don't
like he does
is when he crosses the line and goes
after wife and spouse
and religion and that's when you do that
stuff
your your your market value doesn't
agree it goes down it's not a good level
do you think he does that because he
thinks he's teflon or is that who he is
because that that's a that's his card
tim grover had a response uh which which
we'll get into uh uh and i think
everybody needs to we'll read that
together
i want you to prepare that as well when
we get into it just on your end prepare
that
pentagon cancels a 10 billion dollar
contract given to microsoft over amazon
trump sue's facebook twitter google
claiming censorship will cover that
steve ballmer officially becomes a ninth
person to be a hundred billion dollar
man i know you got opinions about that
uh uh djokovic just wins
wimbledon and claims a record time 20th
grand slam you said usa u.s open today
said uh
no usa today claimed that he's the
greatest tennis player of all time you
have something to say
yes talk about if you're watching this
maybe we'll cover with you as well i
want to know what you think about it
and then he refused to you know during
the applause they gave applause to the
person that invented vaccine and he
asked him about it afterwards i don't
know if we weren't going to cover it or
not we
we may we may not i know adam doesn't
have strong opinions opinions about that
black widow snacks 80 million dollars
from his theatrical debut
60 million from disney that's a scary
thing guys got strong opinions about
that
ashton kutcher said some stuff about
china and tick tock you definitely have
to catch that one
and then you guys got opinions about the
nba stars the game changing right now
some nba players are saying i want to go
back i don't want to you know go to the
nba i'll stay in college
college six different worlds 16 year old
kid just signed a million dollar
contract with over
overtime elite uh jake paul trolling
conor mcgregor he won't stop doing that
there was a certain bond between bezos
branson musk did you guys kind of sense
that like they're working as a team
i thought that competitive edge was kind
of gone rogan getting a little bit more
hate from
spotify employees andy jazzy's first
email to its employees as amazon ceo as
a master class to memo writing
warren buffett allowed dominique sue
to shadow him for several weeks the nfl
star shared his three
key takeaways we'll cover that as well
and then u.s mercenaries who
assassinated former president of haiti
claimed that they were hired as
translators and plot to arrest president
i have some data on this which will go a
little bit
down the rabbit hole i don't even know
if we should or we're not we shouldn't
kai
sent a link i may forward it to you
larry kudlow said something about
red states and blue states and last but
not least
what's going on with cuba right now
which is absolutely
a a disaster but at the same time it's a
good thing to see the people fighting
against the regime uh i retweeted
something aoc said yesterday with a
comment she made i wasn't happy about
what she said but
we'll talk about that so having said
that we got a lot to cover here by the
way
just in fy if anybody is from cuba if
anybody
lived in cuba if anybody can tell us
what it's like to be under that
communistic regime
of cuba so the rest of us can get an
idea about what it looked like i want
you to give us an i and i'm talking
about
you lived there recently i'm not talking
40 years ago i'm talking 10 years ago 5
years ago
15 years ago give me a heads up send us
a message here if you have we'd love to
address that with you
and uh with that being said uh let's get
right into it so okay
out of all the stories we got i said we
start off with a nice little story with
warren buffett and dominic
uh sue how about we go into that story
okay so
warren buffett allows uh dominic sue to
shadow him for several weeks the nfl
star shared his three key takeaways
let's go into what his key three
takeaways worth spending time with
d man d myth the legend this is a
business insider story so
the tampa bay buccaneer player said
every meeting was a hundred times more
valuable
than an nba the football player took
three key takeaways from the billionaire
that have
underpinned his approach to business and
investing ever since
those were to keep things simple that's
number one
focus on passions and people that's
number two
and always read learn and remain curious
about the world let me say that one more
time keep things simple
focus on passions and people always read
learn and remain curious about the world
the six
foot four 305 pound line man also joked
about a stage arm wrestling matches
with buffing in recent years no matter
how many times we do it
i still can't beat him he tweeted must
be all that coca-cola
sue said in january he tries to catch up
with buffett every quarter and he's
gearing up for an investing career after
he retires from football and wants his
mentors
advice thoughts publicity stunt and it
doesn't work for me
okay really it's a duo publicity stunt i
am
so not interested in this and i'll tell
you why
okay and dominic and sue what's he known
for he's known for being
probably the dirtiest nfl player of our
possibly
30 minutes dirty okay nasty like he
could have ended careers he did not give
a damn he's stomping on people sure
hands and he was a very dirty player now
warren buffett is trying to rehabilitate
his image he's had a bad year
if you ask me every time he's kind of a
lot i mean he
he's kind of getting branded as a guy
that you'd be surprised if he can make
his own oatmeal and get dressed in the
morning
right he's he's in his 90s so i think
this is an opportunity that he was
thinking to rehabilitate
his image a little bit in the public eye
um and dominic and sue went to the
universe the university of nebraska so
you're wondering where did this
connection even come from
but why do we care that in dominican
sioux wants to be an investor
how is he even he's not even relevant as
a football player anymore let alone
someone
that's going to branch off and into the
uh investment world i think it was just
a it was an elaborate
attempt for both of these guys to grab
some good publicity
and then if you look at this i mean
warren buffett is a genius
okay he's probably one of the sharpest
people of the last hundred years i mean
you don't accidentally
do what he's done he's unbelievable but
all this stuff that
even his three key takeaways had no
substance to him they were so
basic and and obvious so i i don't think
this helped either of them i think if
you objectively look at it you can kind
of see through it
so i think if there's a publicity stunt
that warren buffett wants to do
if that's what you're going with you got
to pick someone better than in damage
and sue
like that ain't exactly a headlight if
you're saying tom brady
you know shadowed in dominican uh
warren buffett for the last few years
that'd be like holy [ __ ] there's a story
there this is like all right he's a
football player
i get it the nebraska uh um connection
right there
the the biggest thing here is like this
happened in 2010
it was 11 years ago so i was like why
the hell is this even a story
you hit the nail on the head the
nebraska thing he was one of the best
players ever to come out of nebraska he
is one of the dirtiest players in the
nfl
i don't know what you know why he
couldn't clean up his act there
what i will say is i know you're saying
that i have that have that warren
buffett's having a bad year i know you
made it fun that he can't make his own
oatmeal
however i think part of the problem with
warren buffett is
the the argument is that he might be a
little out of touch
these days with today's investor meaning
a lot of young gen z millennials are all
about
they keep calling them out yeah they
they're all about the bitcoin or the
meme stuff
when i interviewed him he did not hold
back from calling him so
um you know it's funny a lot of that
criticism came before the bitcoin and
crypto crash
you know a few months ago because
crypto's gone and the specific argument
is you you haven't outperformed s p 500
last 15 years so it's not even a bitcoin
thing sure yeah
it's you haven't beaten s p 500. how
does hanging within dominican sue make
you hip
it does i think it was a nebraska
connection i think you hit the nail on
the head
i think to wrap this all up to tie it
over to you if you have the opportunity
to shadow warren buffett
you go freaking do that boom bottom line
i mean
so i think look to get a little you know
sportsy here
you know a large percentage of nfl
players go straight up broke within
three to five years of retirement i
think 50
of nba players go broke within five
years of retirement
so if this is what it takes to basically
say hey look i'm playing in the nfl
and i shadowed freaking warren buffett
one of the greatest investors
of all time great arguably the greatest
investor of all time let me take some of
these examples let me take some of these
lessons
bring it to the field what does warren
buffett do for fun
like did he ever buy i think he orders
two egg mcmuffins instead
can you put kai that's
what does warren buffett do for i think
he actually has fun just doing investing
i know he doesn't
know i think he loves the game i don't
think he's like wakeboarding on that go
go on here let's find out tony go go on
warren buffett's favorite hobby if you
go down there well you saw one go back
go back kai go back
top thing warren buffett's favorite
hobby
reading while reading warren buffett's
approach investing it's a hobby that you
generally enjoy okay go back to the 25
things you don't know about warren
buffett let's see
if we first stock he bought he was 11.
keep going
go up okay first talking about he was 11
years old he made 53 000
by the age of 16. by the way that's in a
different era
he was rejected by harvard business
school interesting okay keep going
let's see what number four is we're
looking for fun keep going
little faster guy he it's like a
six-year-old
he lived in the same house since 1958
his father-in-law told him cannot read
that guy
his father-in-law told him his
father-in-law told him he would
fail nice that's always a good motivator
people will pay millions to have lunch
with them
true somebody paid 4.57 million dollars
like a couple years ago
in 2013 buffett earned 37 million
dollars a day
rough nearly 94 of his wealth was earned
after he turned 60 big motivator never
give up keep going
wow number 10 uh uh he never tweeted
before
he's never tweeted before that's cool
keep going
uh 11 buffett owns 20 suits but has
never paid for any
he's still awesome he spends 80 of his
day reading
fantastic uh buffett will give an
employee a million dollars every year
for the rest of his life
his or her life if they can guess the
ncaa sweet 16 teams that's pretty fast
there's a hobby right there he likes
march madness that's right that's a good
point that's a good thing right there he
ditched his flip phone for an iphone in
2020 20
20. he takes a dozen kids to dairy queen
every sunday
wow that's cool buffett rarely emails
okay keep going 17 he plays
ukulele buffett pledged to donate 85
percent of his berkshire berkshire
hathaway stock to charitable foundations
okay
he was the winner olympics he was the
awarded the presidential medal of
freedom by barack obama out of all
investing legends buffett has the same
best track record for beating the market
impressive his face was on cherry coke
cans in china in china okay
he doesn't follow anyone on twitter he's
a big fan of breaking bad
wow that's a good look keep going is
that him well what is that that's
actually him
that's actually the coolest picture born
i've ever seen that's actually coolest
picture
he likes to joke around okay we know
that he looks to a poem
when markets decline no one can tell you
when those will happen more than others
i'm going to extraordinary opportunities
if you can keep your head when all about
you are losing theirs
when all about you are losing theirs if
you can wait
and not be tired of waiting if you can
think and not make thoughts your aim
if you can trust yourself when all men
doubt you yours
is the earth and everything that's in it
okay
all right cool do we have another one or
two can i can i make it here's how your
mind can play tricks on you and your
eyes if you could
go back to that list kai go back to the
very bottom of it go back to number 25
take a quick glance at number 25 and
then look away i literally when i first
saw that i thought he looks to porn i
thought that's what it said he looks
important
insider does their stories they wait for
number 25 he's an insider all right so
when tom zender spent time with him he
noticed how much point he was
that's probably what his three i got to
tell you when i hung out with warren
buffett all we did was watch porn
that's all we did i can actually see you
doing that pat was wondering what he
does for fun i don't know
there we go okay all right so yeah so
you can leave uber
we have planned to learn what's that he
plays bridge though
good for him he doesn't play back i mean
nothing makes you seem more out of touch
i mean that's all you need to know
there's like 200 i feel like that's in
touch you're
hanging with okay so let's continue
let's continue gang again if you're from
if you lived in cuba for at least 10
years where you have memories of what
that place was like and it was recent
text us at 310-340-1132 we'd like to
call you and get perspective on what it
was like to be in cuba and why you and
your family escaped
cuba let's continue ashton kutcher had
some interesting things to say about
china and uh it's it's interesting to
come from somebody that was an a-lister
hollywood star who's now a big business
mogul
who was once with demi moore and now
with uh mila kunis i believe
everyone knows who he is he's in the
investment world and here's what he had
to say
ashton kutcher wants that china warns
that china could use tick tock to push
anti-us propaganda and create a problem
influencing
young americans he continues this is a
blaze
media story during his time in office
former president donald trump issued an
executive order banning these chinese
creators and owned social media
platforms insisting that the app would
be used to spread disinformation
campaigns
benefiting the chinese communistic party
and jeopardizing america's national
security president joe biden however
revoked the order upon taking office if
i'm china and i want to use
you i want to create a problem in that
area of the world
specifically a naval problem in the
south china sea
i would probably want to utilize tick
tock in order to influence the minds of
americans kutcher said
in the early in early june tick tock
quietly updated its privacy policy with
regards to united states users
allowing itself to collect u.s users
biometric
data to include voice prints and face
prints now ashton kutcher to say
something about china
what do you think about that it's
unbelievable actually um
talk about almost going out of your way
to canceling yourself though those are
the two things you cannot do in
hollywood
inadvertently praise trump which he did
if you read between the lines
and then dog china he did both of them
which makes me think his investments are
doing very very well because he has the
ability
to have a platform and not really care
what he thinks or what anybody thinks
about it it probably means he's going to
be doing the sequel the next five
sequels to dude where's my car because
it's probably gonna be hard
to get a major movie finance but i think
it's very
it's very telling it's very interesting
and you wonder what the next steps are
like will there be
uh any sort of action against him in
hollywood is this gonna hurt his career
does he even have a career i don't even
know how much he cares about doing
movies anymore
because he's not really doing him and he
seems more his brand is about a tech
investor
and being cutting edge with some of the
businesses he gets involved in but
look he's got bigger uh aspirations for
himself here i think for making these
types of comments
he's a visionary he's smart maybe he's
going to get a little conversation going
but this is going to hurt his career in
hollywood
but i love what he said by the way fun
fact about ash and kutcher
demi moore and mila kunis he's the two
women he's been married to they both
went to the same high school
get out of it yeah they both went to
hollywood high which is what are the
odds right that's incredible what's the
last movie culture made by the way
what's the last big movie he did and
that's a serious question
you know what how about that one he did
with cameron diaz when they went to
vegas and they got married that was
at least 15. that was 2008 i think okay
i'm doing so
so here we go so we have uh vengeance
he's doing self-production okay
the long home it's a 2021 movie
completed
the ranch tv series which he was on 26th
into 2020
family guy 2016 two and a half men 2011
to 2015.
two and a half men he didn't have to do
anything after that a movie though
that's a tv series
charlie sheen's job okay annie
men at work the last movie he did was
jobs 2013. so this guy hasn't done
movies for eight years 2013
2013 movie yeah not shows great movie
2013. yeah
and you think he cares i don't do you
think he i don't think he looks at
himself as an actor
number one anymore look i'll give you my
two cents on ashton kutcher the guy has
come a long way since
you know being uh on the 70s show or
even on punk by the way i love punk
anyone in the audience who's watching
let us know if you love punk too
i thought he killed it at that but he
hasn't done that a long time look he's
transitioned from being just a hollywood
guy
uh dude where's my car i'm high as [ __ ]
on the 70s show
and debunking people to an actual
silicon valley
investor big time entrepreneur here's
some of the companies that he's invested
in
uber airbnb and he's all about acorns
the investing app which
we've talked about from time to time so
he's
he's built credibility in the business
world and i
clearly he don't give two shits about
going against hollywood or
certainly going against china and i
gotta give him props for actually
calling out china
and specifically you know in a
roundabout way kind of agreeing with
trump here on on what tick tock's
influence or
soft power sneaky power creeping out on
the american youth
may be happening and and china's
disinformation campaigns
so bottom line respect to ashton kutcher
for what he's doing
former model from iowa small town in
iowa too by the way
by the way and and while you look at
this this is this guy's he calls himself
a fiscally conservative
socially liberal independent but leans
towards the democratic party is showing
support to
hillary clinton and barack obama and has
a distaste towards republicans
like donald trump so now here's here
sounds like my kind of guy here's here's
a question though here's a question
though
this goes back to this goes back to a
conversation we once had
kai you look like you want to say
something yeah he also co-founded a uh
company for against child trafficking by
the way he spoke about it to congress
yeah which went viral inactive and that
was a
against human traff child trafficking
that him and demi moore started together
i believe this was years ago well think
about if you're going to marry
a woman who's i'm guessing 15
years as senior i'm guessing demi yeah
yeah
um you're gonna grow up a little bit
you're going to you're not going to be
just a goofy
30 year old kid just kind of joking
around because a lot of people didn't
take their relationships seriously
exactly 15 years she's 58.
he's 40 gotcha so you're going to kind
of grow up a little bit faster than a
typical 30 year old whenever they got
married and you're going to start
tackling
some real world issues you're not going
to be out in the club partying like a
typical 30 year old
you're hanging with a grown-ass woman
demi moore one of the most
gorgeous womens of all time in my
opinion and you're going to grow up and
you're going to tackle some real life
issues i.e
child trafficking and investing and
china so again respect yeah you know
what
the the companies that you mentioned
that he invested in he got in early so
he made
unbelievable killings in multiple by the
way his net worth guess his net worth
300 300 mil pbd guess his net worth two
hundred countries he's a 200 yeah
200 okay exactly yeah but i mean that
gives you so much freedom when when
you've done that and you can have that
platform he doesn't have to care he
could fund his own movies if he wanted
to so
there's a couple things i take away from
this number one number one
uh there's a movement happening within
hollywood
okay who are not republicans who are not
who are not democrats but they're
worried
the fact that this thing could go to
socialism this thing can go to
controlling what you could say and what
you can't say what movies you can and
you can't make
and it's him connor and uh not conor uh
matthew mcconaughey
that are coming out matthew's time is
coming out of common sense independence
like listen this is a little too much
and by the way yeah
even if when uh yeah but but bill maher
is still
left though bill maher is the lab is not
these guys no no but congratulations
you're right absolutely i totally agree
bill maher is a left guy that's kind of
like what the hell are we doing exactly
have you lost your mind exactly and by
the way you know who else doesn't agree
with the direction america is going
right now that people would be surprised
with
a guy named barack obama is not happy
with the direction things are going
right now he himself was like listen man
you know
kind of temper it down a little bit with
the association even two names the other
day
sean penn very leftist type of guy
uh semi-socialist yes yeah fan of hugo
chavez yeah what i recall yeah
and conan o'brien you know it's more of
a common sense jokester but definitely
i think conan is a center game yeah but
they
they both called out the woke cancel
culture out there
look we talk about this all the time not
to get too political here sometimes
you need people on your team to
basically say look i don't like what
you're doing
rather than people on the other side
calling you out absolutely that's what's
happening in the democratic party right
here's what i would tell you this is the
other part this is the other part this
is the other part that people are gonna
have to
argue and it's gonna favor one guy i
hate to say this but it's gonna favor
one guy
so just a few months ago when trump gave
the speech at sp cpac
and there were you know voter approval
people wanting him to run et cetera et
cetera he was at 50
okay just this last week when he ran i
think it was like he spoke to them i
think it was 76
yeah and second place was the santa's 21
right
so he went from 50 to 70 and desantis 21
which they're talking about him and
desantis president
vp type of thing to go out there and do
it now we'll see if that's going to take
place or not
here's what i will tell you take the
name out
take the name out of trump and just look
at his policy
frozen frozen no it says it's not fruit
so
it's reconnecting are we back guys
no it's streaming live on youtube are we
back we're back can you guys if you guys
can hear us and see us let me know if
you guys can hear or see us
i'm seeing a lot of comments you can let
me know if we're back okay we're back
okay good
where'd we pick off what i was talking
about okay what's the last thing you
heard me say i'm curious
tell me what's the last thing you heard
me say what is the last thing
i want to know what they heard me say
here last what's the last thing you
heard me say let me know and then time
this guy
so we can cut this later on what's the
last thing you heard me say just tell me
what's the last thing you heard me say
there's a short lag okay well we're back
just what is the last thing you heard me
say that's all i care about
uh i want to know what's the last thing
you heard me say
take trump's name okay so it takes
trump's name out okay
so take trump's name out let's take
trump's name out okay and you go look at
his policies
you look at what his policies did how
many people on the left center and right
are starting to realize yes he may have
been a divisive guy
yes he may have been a guy that was
pinning everybody you know he was doing
what he was doing battling against the
mainstream media all the stuff that he
was doing
but his policies made a lot of sense he
called out tick-tock
everybody disagreed now ashton kutcher
are saying that
he he was handling the border very well
now we have issues at the border they
don't even want to touch it
we were doing okay with getting the
vaccine to be expedited in nine months
on how quickly he got a vaccine
fauci said it will take 18 months at the
earliest to get it out
his sanctions against cuba that he put
on nine months ago
saying if cuba doesn't get it together
the entire world is going to be free we
have to make sure the entire world is
free
and we have to let go of those political
prisoners that cuba has what do you
think the
cuban people right now are protesting
here's the point
i think there's a part of the current
elections
the process that we have that i don't
agree with
and i don't know what it is here's
here's one of the things
we we vote more for personality than
policies today
if we took out the personality
mainstream media couldn't do what they
do let me explain
if all we said is we have three things
we're campaigning on
this is a this is b this is c take away
personalities it's purely policies
that we're campaigning on right who do
you bash what do you bash
who cares the policies don't grab
anybody but you know what policies don't
go out there and do
what sniffing somebody's uh hair
with what biden does right if you just
put it on policies how do you trash the
policies
you can't say a person you can't pin
them to you just have to say
that policy just kind of makes sense i
agree with that policy so there's
no more to rage emotionally against the
personality you
dislike because the media keeps talking
about this guy's a bad guy this guy's a
bad guy this guy's a bad guy
so i kind of like the fact that common
sense has started to win a little bit
because long-term bad ideas get exposed
and long-term
great ideas win that's what's happening
here here's the problem though
it's one thing to have these people at
least call it out and reference it and
acknowledge it
but how do you get to the next point
where something actually happens because
of it
they've just given way too much power to
the far
far fringe left they are letting them
get away with anything they want
anything they say is not challenged and
that makes their job 10 times more
difficult i think
trump should not run for president i
really because don't you
he's so polarizing and people hate him
so much i don't run for vice president
there's no chance i'll give you three
seconds to retract
for the good country no way support
desantis oh by the way no no it's not
trump it's either being what president
either a president or don't run again he
ain't doing no vp stuff because he's
already been up there
that's that'll never happen if you truly
care about the country which he does
no i mean don't you think there's almost
no chance for him to get elected he
definitely he brings out the worst out
of so many people in this country well
listen i'm gonna announce something this
week i'm gonna announce something this
week if you see it on social which you
will if you see it on my instagram you
will we're going to talk about on the
podcast next week
i'm going to launch something what i
think is going to be a solution to help
unite america
the idea is going to be crazy the idea
is going to be nuts i'm going to put a
lot of money behind it it's going to be
public
and you have to choose whether you want
to see this thing become a reality or
not and
when you do see it if you agree with it
help spread the message
everywhere once the announcement is made
i will be most likely making that
announcement either this friday
or next monday sometime this week or
monday that announcement's going to be
made
you will be shell-shocked what the
announcement is it it is about
but if you do agree with it i want to
make sure the world hears about it going
back to this
you know what's exciting about this the
fact that people are voicing their
opinions that they never would have
the fact that hollywood is voicing their
brain fyi you know you know
no you know why people and hollywood
actors are no longer intimidated by
hollywood anymore you know why
let me tell you why perfect transition
into the story of black widow
[Music]
black widow snags 80 million dollars
from its theatrical debut
60 million from disney plus folks let me
read that to you one more time
black widow okay out of the 80 million
60 million is from disney plus black
widow has stolen the pandemic era box
office crown the latest marvel film
scored 80 million dollars at the
domestic box office during its debut
the most of any film released in the
wake of covet
epidemic over the weekend around 81 of
the theaters were open to the public
according to the data of comscore
universal's f9 fast and furious 9 was
the previous record holder
getting 70 million over his three-day
launch into theaters last month
the film garnered an additional 60
million dollars from disney plus sales
in addition to black widow tallied 78
million from international ticket sales
here's what this means let me tell you
why actors are no longer scared
of hollywood here's why um this
is not the typical movie you know
hollywood thing that you're doing
netflix is coming right now they want
oscars they want academies they want
grant they want uh whatever it is that
whatever they're giving away the awards
for best movies
actors are sitting there saying listen
man hollywood those days have a handful
of you guys having all the power in the
world they can't push us around you
can't do that anymore
you don't have that kind of authority
anymore the days where weinstein pre me
too movement
the days where weinstein had everybody
like stronghold in
everybody strong armin everybody you
can't do that anymore today
so hollywood actors are feeling a little
bit more
confident and liberated hollywood for
the longest time was almost a
dictatorship today
yesterday i come i get back to the
office i was in urban land
i come to the office first thing in the
morning you know what's sitting on my
table right now you know what's sitting
on my desk right now a script
a guy sends me a message saying i love
what you're talking about i got a script
for you
i'd love for you to invest into our
script or buy your script from us
sitting over there we're starting to get
more scripts than ever before
what does this mean a person can have
money one ten million fifty million
twenty five million dollars i'm gonna do
a movie here you go
and then you can go pitch it to who
others rather than going and selling you
to traditional hollywood route
so i think the ashton kutchers of the
world and all these other guys are
getting comfortable because you're
seeing what happened with the black
widow movie
all right is this the plus is this is it
watching the movie no need to go to the
movie theater is it essentially becoming
almost like a cryptocurrency type of
decentralized platform it's not just in
hollywood anymore you got it's a great
disney plus you've got netflix you got
amazon you got the
you can go down the whole freaking list
and the hulu's in the disney that's
actually great
and it's just not decentralized now the
the harvey weinsteins of the world to
use your analogy
don't control hollywood anymore welcome
to the studio it's a great thing for a
lot of people it's the studios that
don't control hollywood anymore and by
the way barry diller one of the legends
who ran two of them what paramount
and uh universal i think he said last
week that
the movie business is dead he literally
set out he said the going to the theater
experience the movie business
is dead and it's never coming do you
agree with them i 100
agree with them and you know never
netflix doesn't release streaming
figures like this disney
to say 60 million that that's uncommon
for them to actually
release that but that's unbelievable i
would never go to a movie theater again
i don't think i have no upside to going
to with you
who's got the time for it what movie did
i watch i don't know didn't you go to a
movie theater i mean if i take the kids
oh we watch fast
fast and furious yeah i gave it a seven
it was actually a good movie
you gave the nine a seven no i give the
nine a seven yeah i give the nine to
seven i took the kids i hate when that
happens
i go home with the nine and you wake up
at the seven i accidentally took the
kids to mortal kombat
i accidentally took the kiss to mortal
kombat
till today yeah there's not a day when i
bring up movies where they don't bring
up mortal kombat what do they say well
you're the one that took us to mortal
kombat the worst movie of all time but i
said i've taken you to
50 movies you've loved one of them and
the last thing we need is dylan and tico
fighting we know we saw what happened
earlier
they had one of the most epic fights of
all time in aruba and yeah here's what
happened the fight i'm not going to tell
you the details of the fight but they
had a pretty big fight because
dylan threw santiko's face accidentally
apparently accidentally
i wasn't there to witness that mario was
so i walk up because mario's like you
got to come here to the beach dylan's
running off it's pretty epic crazy
stuff's going on with these guys
and you got to realize the robots are
very calm place the water has no waves
like literally there is no waves where
we are at the ritz carlton resort
i walk up and i go to the kids i'm
walking back this husband and wife good
looking couple in their 50s right
they kind of takes care of themselves
you know she's wearing the two-piece
he's got the whole nice six-pack
they said you're not gonna tell you we
love your boys i said really tell me why
it says
for the last hour all we've been
following is what your boys have been
doing
your two sons we can tell those two are
your sons but the other two are now your
sons right i said no why
this is because the other two are too
nice he says
for one hour straight we've been
following them and we love what they're
doing the fighting the awards all that
stuff thank you so much for giving us
entertainment i said well they take
they'll take a hundred dollar tip from
you
anyway so we had a good time out there
with that back to the uh so they
they they will not let them they will
not mortal combat is done that's not
gonna happen
real quick just a couple a little thing
to add you talking about the movie
studios paramount
and um universal and universal but
wasn't it didn't amazon just buy mgm
yeah okay so that i mean there's another
further example they did it just for
more content in their library
here here's how i don't i don't go to
the movie theaters like period i think
the last one i went to was like i took
my ex-girl to go see
winnie the pooh like back in the like
three years ago and be honest who were
you dating otherwise yeah
she was 25 but you know she probably
acted like she was five however
this is how out of touch i am by the way
no she's not little she's listening she
dm's me
she's got me blocking she's got me
blocked um
[Music]
what was the best part of winnie the
pooh when he got his head stuck in the
honey jar
okay you got your hand called the cookie
jar anyway here's how to
how you're a high roller when you take
your girl to a winnie the pooh yeah hey
by the way
you know today's thank you for the
immortal combination yes i'm actually
going to play more on completely
different
food than in movie time by the way that
story yeah it actually gets you closer
to soul boy than further away
you know here's my point let me finish
my point and then i'm going to uh
this is how out of touch i am with
movies when i when i hear this story
black widow grosses 80 million dollars
i'm thinking oh [ __ ] they came out with
like
the female version of the black panther
then i look it up and it's freaking
white girl scarlett johansson the black
widow i'm surprised that's not cancelled
culture yet
yeah i'm just telling you stop it i
don't give a [ __ ] i'm just saying i'm
surprised that there's people out there
being like black widow
white ass scarlett johansson what the
hell is going on folks if you're
listening to this adam's not right
adam thinks adam thinks if you don't
know this already or not adam thinks
fast and the furious is a continuation
of knight rider
that's how old school
by the way you should show the poster
you have in your office of david
hasselhoff of knight rider they should
see it
i don't think people really say that's
not a night writer it's the baywatch
it's the baywatch one
sure big david hasselhoff okay all right
so ashton kutcher kudos to you by the
way
if you agree with ashton kutcher put a
thumbs up
one it gives us an idea if you do agree
with them or not two
helps us out with algorithms and if you
like the direction the content's going
we are 33 that we're officially at 67
000 subs we're 33 000 subs away from a
hundred thousand
once we hit a hundred thousand we may
convert to three times a week instead of
two times a week so give us a sub as
well if you enjoy the point
[ __ ] we're getting there yeah we're
getting close we're getting close
let's continue let's continue not
escaped available to come to america we
would like to get optics from you on
what it was like to live in cuba
and why you're so happy to be in america
what does freedom really mean to you
having left a place like cuba to come to
the states
is marvin from cuba no he's marvin's
i apologize to my honduran i was just
with him we had one of the best
conversations ever okay
all right let's go so uh ufc 264
real or not the old conor mcgregor is
gone forever dustin porter is a top
light heavyweight
the ufc's 264 main event only lasted one
round but dustin did plenty in his
victory over counter to prove he
deserves the first
title shot at charles oliveira is
pourier already the best lightweight in
the world as for conor mcgregor the
misstep that caused the serious leg
injury brought the fight to an abrupt
end
is an elite version of counter a thing
of the past
and where does he go from here kai can
you pull up a grover's uh
instagram post about about connor
everybody must read this
uh by the way shout out to tim he just
sent me three nice uh air jordan shoes
each one of them real sick shoes like
michael's from his book just became a
new york times bestseller
sick book if you haven't ordered you
ought to do it okay when conor mcgregor
lost to khabib he was exposed by the
limelight and has
never found his way back to the true
darkness that had
allowed him to win winning one except
this version of counter because this
connor still thinks
and acts like he's winning and winning
knows he is not let me read that one
more time winning won't accept this
version of counter
because this connor still thinks and
acts like he's winning
and winning knows he's not this loss to
dustin is about so much more
than an injury if you've read winning
you get this he hasn't taken that
necessary bus ride back to hell
winners know that in order to repeat
they have to get on that bus
along with all their demons and monsters
and skeletons asking
now what conor can't answer them because
that bus ride needs to be taken in
silence
winning requires real talk or no talk at
all the only thing you hear
are the silencing of your heartbeat and
the shortening of your breath
as you you approach hell you have no
choice you can either commit
to taking the bus ride to hell and fight
your way back to winning
or hell will come for you anyway snatch
your heart
out of your chest and make you watch it
stop as you take
your last breath and you lose forever
that's the difference between taking
yourself to hell
and health taking you one you can't
control the other you are done
more in winning read it there you go
thoughts encounter
i mean dude this guy's got credibility
galore because this is exactly what
michael jordan did year in and year out
yeah i mean this is what tim grove is
known for working with mj
what do you think it's kind of do you
think conor's done yes
as an elite mma fighter there's
absolutely no question you cannot even
make the argument that he's not it's
impossible to make that argument
i think dana white has a real problem
because he doesn't really have
a stable of stars outside of conor
mcgregor that's why they keep doing what
they're doing i mean
have you guys ever been to a live ufc
fight yeah i mean the energy is just
simply off the charts i've been to two
title fights in vegas
absolutely i went well my friend is ryan
bader so he fought twice once he fought
jon jones and then he fought oh he lost
he lost both of those unfortunately but
he's doing great in bellator
but dana white has a problem he doesn't
have any stars now it's not going to
hurt the business they just brought in
175 million dollars from a crypto
company
for their biggest sponsorship ever but
you know what conor mcgregor is the next
wait for it ronda rousey that's all he
is right now he's nothing more
he's nothing more than that he's next
bigger than ronda rousey no no timeout
no he
in the mma he's not his next fight is
going to be
against jake paul because it'll be for
nine figures
easy dana white will eventually get
behind it and have to promote him i
think that's why he keeps him relevant
in in ufc so he can sanction that fight
but you know what that's the one i'd
watch i'm not interested in watching
conor fight in the ufc anymore
he's not at that level he's not at the
elite league no it's funny you brought
up something last week when you said
look if there's ever a time
that dana white makes a phone call to
dustin poirier and says look here's
here's a couple bucks take this hit that
clearly didn't happen he didn't get that
phone call first of all
i like the approach conor took with the
fight he started with the kicks i like
the way he started the fight but the
moment he went on the ground gerard was
saying this yesterday
this guy to learn how to wrestle and and
be on the ground i mean you have to
learn how to
get out of it for four minutes he was
stuck and dustin wasn't even pounding
this guy
he wasn't even destroyed but what
happens when you're down there is you're
gonna lose all the stamina
you can't last when you get the moment
he got up the last 15 seconds i don't
know if you saw that or not
yeah the 15 seconds when he got up did
you see his energy did you see like he
was
he was done like he didn't have the
energy anymore which means
stamina is a problem i told the guys my
prediction was if conor wins
he wins in the first round if it goes
past first round
dustin wins no question by the way if he
wouldn't have broken his leg like his
ankle say that wouldn't have happened to
his ankle i think we got the [ __ ] kicked
out of him around oh it would have been
done
and it's even worse and he's a bloody
mess but you know what his strength you
know
his success came from his feet so if he
can't
have that as a weapon anymore i mean
he's broken his leg twice now
with kicks so i mean his number one
strength has given completely neutered
from him
so there's no way he can compete at that
level because he's not a boxer or a
wrestler let me tell you something
you you brought up a good point here
that i don't know where ufc goes from
here because i would
i would i would call myself a casual fan
meaning i don't know much about ufc
but if conor mcgregor's fighting i'm
gonna watch it
now without connor i don't know who i
would give two shits about i don't think
about
this i get that i'm just saying me i
wouldn't go watch that but let me just
important
not that billy mcgillicuddy but you're
gonna watch let me explain no i'm not i
promise you guys what happened
let me tell you why you're gonna watch
here's why you're to watch okay
never underestimate the power of dana
white what are we talking about here
like
when when dana had a couple guys step
away you forget who stepped away like
you want to go back and look at the list
of play
put down the greatest ufc fighters of
all time can you put them up just put
the greatest ufc fighters of all time
randy i don't know where you're going
with this let me nobody's even close to
drawing what conor does
listen but i'm i'm i'm i'm still
listening stop stop go
greatest ufc fighters all the time when
khabib stepped away they said it's over
who's going to watch it okay
keep going up keep going up dude i never
even heard of khabib b.j
that's the point royce gracie keep going
these are these are all killers
keep going keep going up keep going up
with these names keep going up with
these names keep going
keep going up keep reading these top
five go to top five usman is still in
the game you got
uh liddell ten years i know when they
stepped away they said the league is the
yeah ufc is going to be boring keep
going keep going keep going keep going
7-6
is gone cormier's gone a lot of these
guys george saint pierre was like
ghana years ago but what i'm trying to
tell you is the franchise keeps getting
bigger and bigger
anderson silva was a god jon jones god
this guy's had godzilla john jones would
come in
in the press conference would knock the
other guy out and press conference
i mean you're talking about guys that
sold out arenas where people would come
from around
you got to bank on dana but this is
about counterwriting it's not about
being listen i'm a buy and hold guy with
connor i bought his best card this is
his rookie 2013 tops
ufc bloodlines psa 10 gemint and auto
10. this is counter
i'm a buy and hold guy the only thing
that concerns me about conor is when he
plays
the spouse and the religion game you
cannot do that
you become a target you cannot play that
game i understand like
ronda rousey sent a message right
afterwards i don't know if you guys saw
what rhonda said about him right
afterwards can you pull up rhonda's
tweet right afterwards towards conor did
you guys read that i didn't see it so
rhonda said this about conor the next uh
uh just pull it up let's see uh yeah
pull up um
uh is it this one okay uh uh so i'm
amazed that as soon as you hit the
ground you were already promoting the
next fight
i definitely wouldn't have had that in
mind to do that the other fighters ufc
and the media are lucky to have you
i disagree everybody in the world is
lucky to have conor mcgregor
everybody is lucky to have conor
mcgregor but to have that mindset where
you drop
first thing you're thinking about is the
next fight are you a promoter or a
fighter i don't know are you still
promoting to make money or are you
so my mind goes to a couple different
places here's a couple different places
it goes to a counter
some guy right now commented and says
he's not gone somebody said let me read
who it was it says scott smith gave 10
bucks and so i'll make the argument
conor was dominating their second bout
uh conor looked amazing in the third
bout i don't know about that maybe in
the first 90 seconds but the moment he
was down he was gone connor ain't done
he was gearing up to take pacquiao okay
i agree here's a problem scott and it's
my opinion
amateur opinion somebody can destroy my
argument but this is my argument
when i was talking to tim grover here's
what tim grover said
tim has meant tim is uh training uh
jordan
and when he's training jordan jordan
decides to go out there and uh play
baseball he said i want to go play
baseball
tim says the entire conditioning has
officially changed
this is what you mean he says to prepare
your body for baseball
it's very different than preparing your
body for basketball
it's a very different conditioning and
it's going to take a while to do that
what's the point to prepare a
conditioning for
boxing pacquiao is very different than
to prepare
a fight in ufc boxing you ain't going to
the ground everybody knows conor's a
great boxer
but his ground game is not the best
you're going against guys where you have
to spend
majority of your time working in areas
where you don't do well with
let's set it let's say tell what
happened with this guy he's been choked
out he's been
khabib got him on the ground he doesn't
do well on the ground once he he didn't
want to go down when he bit diaz
how did he be diaz first fight he lost
he went to the ground
second fight if you see that one scene i
don't know if you guys remember this
with diaz
they're going at it he's punching diaz
he falls down he punches him second not
before remember that
he punches him he falls down and diaz is
like come on come on come get me
connor's standing up he's not going that
message tells you
you come to the ground i'm going to
destroy you and connor says i know i'm
not good there
but i'm good at stand up so standing a
stand-up game he's got but if you're
going against some of these other guys
make a point i'm gonna ask you a
question one through ten ten being the
most
one being i don't give a [ __ ] here we go
where are you on a
being a fan of ufc i'm
i'm a fan what number eight and a half
you're an eight and a half yeah
i'm a six point five i'm a five and i go
for the start
okay meaning a guy like you who's eight
and a half a nine and ten
they're gonna watch ufc regardless six
and a half maybe
you're gonna watch maybe not a five i'm
only watching if a guy like conor
mcgregor is fighting
if pick a name is is fighting pick a
name
dude i've never even heard of khabib
until like a year ago they know why it
doesn't give a [ __ ] to have a fan like
you what are you talking about
by the way are you talking are you
out of your mind dude let me ask you a
question let me ask you a question
let me ask you a question you want a
simple question how much money have you
ever made for ufc
you like 50 bucks when was it i bought
one fight with connor
okay there you haven't made him [ __ ] so
who cares if he loses you you got i
bought
no you don't mean anything today no
wrong approach you're not a spender
that's the wrong approach it's not the
wrong approach okay i hear you you're
not a spender you're not a guy that's
bringing revenues to the brand that's
like david stern when he was promoting
the nba being like
we don't need to expand we have our base
they love the nba they're buying seasons
but then he invested in jordan
you're making a mistake and comparing
dana to freaking
david stone what are you talking about
he's saying dude to the next
do you know what part of the world ufc's
fighting can you pull up
different uh countries ufc has had a
fight in you give me a free what you
just said right there was ludicrous
says you know nothing about what's going
on with you saying are you casual
what are you talking about you're not a
spender though you're irrelevant to ufc
you're only thinking in terms of
monetization talking about you you are
irrelevant to ufc
that's it dana white me and you are done
you are irrelevant to ufc here we go you
ready
okay us brazil canada uk australia japan
china germany sweden mexico ireland
singapore
dubai united arab emirates netherlands
new zealand poland russia argentina
chile croatia
do you want me to keep going this guy is
a global brand
you've been doing why you woke up saying
i better get adam sauce
right now oh my gosh guys how the hell
can we
go back to watching winnie the pooh
stick to your winnie the pooh fight
you know what this was good they should
say i'd watch two rounds of this i pay
50 bucks for you to continue
he's the best commissioner in sports as
a matter of fact i'd make the argument
that
he should be i agree with you he should
do a two-year term in every sport and
fix every sport while he's at it by the
way i spent a couple hours with
dana white one time flew up hung out
with him in his office did this long
interview with him
his office i may have mentioned this
before it is the you can tell there's no
hr department at ufc when you walk into
dana white's office it is flat out
unbelievable what you see in there
but let me bring this back to the topic
and you two are both delusional and so
is everybody else that said
conor mcgregor is relevant as a ufc
fighter a
number one there's no sport where hunger
controls
everything if you're not hungry you are
dead
or seriously injured in ufc you are
completely irrelevant and you have no
chance
to fight at the highest level what does
he give you
in his mind part of it's going i hope
this ends soon i hope i don't get hurt
he's not this he's not the same guy
he is not the same guy as a fighter that
doesn't mean he isn't one of the top
global stars in the country and he's not
going to be relevant forever
he's elvis jumpsuit as a fighter i want
to know why i'm right on this one oh my
gosh because if we were talking about
any other fighter other than conor this
story would have been done
actually fights dustin diamond from
saved by the belt let me let me rest in
peace let me
let me watch that fight let me shout out
to screech i miss you buddy let me put
it to you this way let me put it to you
this way
any game that is very good with their
number ones
is gonna have people that are gonna work
like dogs they're gonna work like
like military work like i'm talking work
work to go be number ones because they
take you their number ones
ufc may not be an organization that's
known for taking care of their number 80
or their number 40. we know the
criticism jake paul goes after him a lot
of people have been saying what they've
been saying about the fact that
a lot of the athletes are not making
money but if there's one thing ufc is
known for is what they take care of
their number one their number ones are
gonna make a lot of money right
you know how many people right now are
sitting there this is what they're
thinking
how many people right now are saying
that position for number one is wide
open
i'm going to go get it same thing
happens to great sports when the
jordan left who's going to replace
jordan kobe came kobe left who's going
to approach
lebron lebron yes look what's going on
right now with giannis giannis
2-1 they're down but he's got 40 points
back to back the last time milwaukee
broke over
in 1971. oh by the way i just thought of
something what's that
the the the guy i couldn't tell you his
name to uh
uh he knocked the [ __ ] out of the uh
of uh greg hardy and he drank a beer out
of his shoe
i'm in on that guy okay all right who's
that guy will you spend 20 bucks on that
guy
save that money however what's that
guy's name i'm not the customer i know
he knows what's going to matter what's
his name what's his name
pbd what's his name nobody knows his
name exactly nobody knows
are you insinuating that there is me and
you we each take a tennis shoe and we
chug a beer
we'll donate the money to charity first
of all if you're watching this if you're
watching this if you're watching this
i'm actually curious let's see what the
audience can let me actually look at the
ratio let me actually
look at the ratio so right now we got
390 thumbs up to seven thumbs down
okay how many of you think that connor
is not done
put thumbs up connor's not good as an
elite fighter
listen as an elite fighter he's going to
come back and he's going to put on a
fight and he's going to win
again and maybe even have a shot at a
title fight
he's 32 years old today how many guys
think he's going to make a comeback put
thumbs up if you think he's going to
make a comeback
and redeem himself thumbs up if you say
the guy is done it's retirement time
put thumbs down what do you think on
which one it is
me last week when the fight took place i
commented i said the
the fan base is lucky to have a guy like
this to see him fight at his peak
and we've been talking about conor the
moment he got that 200 million dollar
payday from
proper 12. it's a different counter if
he's not willing to listen to a guy like
tim what he just said and going to that
place to want to fight again
we ain't going to see the best the best
days of counter are behind him if he
does go to that dark place and really
want to come back and make a come back
and redeem himself
we may see i don't know how you see it
right now let's see what the ratios are
couple quick comments when you're ready
uh number one the guy's name that i
didn't know was uh
tai okay that's number one
number two um in case we want to write
this down where did that go where did
that go where did that go
um the guy who said he's 41 years old
and he
moved from cuba when he was seven years
old i'm looking for your comment
uh what number should he call if that's
the guy you want to talk to
you have it okay oh you have that hey by
the way how old was he when he moved
uh seven years ago okay good and shout
out to tom zenner they said
these are my three favorite combo pat
adam and tom thanks crypto mike
shout out to tom zenner right there okay
thank you hey by the way the guy had
some great comments as khabib
after this fight and he broke it down
and said hey this is who conor is
you know when he was on the ground now
there tmz had a story where there was a
side angle of a camera where he was
actually threatening to kill
uh poirier's wife and and and him he's
going to shoot him in the head in the
middle of the night
he can't do that so khabib's point is
this guy is nothing but a low-rank punk
you know his true colors what dustin
called him he said this comes back
dirtbag
no these guys have legitimate hate for
him and the last thing that um
conor mcgregor wants to do is step in a
ring with khabib when he threw that
stanchion at the bus in brooklyn or in
new york city at madison square but you
know what
in conner's mind it's all promotion and
i think
everything is on the table when it comes
to him everything
and that's why the next step for him has
to be an event that he can actually win
he has no chance of winning a ufc fight
unless he's fighting a guy like cyrone
or
cowboy the guy the last guy he beats but
that's not but that's who he can be
that's not real he'd be that guy like
three seconds
believe it or not the ratios is 53 think
his best
he can come back and have a title fight
35 think he's done which means
a lot of people are saying the best days
of conor are behind them and we may
never see
by the way i don't know if this is
something we can pull up i'd like to see
the numbers pay-per-view revenue
with connor without connor i bet you
it's a complete difference
sure it is okay that's my point but
there is a guy yeah that you keep
forgetting about you keep forgetting
about the guy you know the cop
who is forgetting about it he's one of
the greatest promoters instigators
of all time the guy's going to figure
out a way to do it fyi i think there's
only one connor though bro
oh my gosh stop i don't he's that
brilliant of a marketer you know what
let me tell you something
one of the things that you [ __ ] right
now one of the things i respect about
what michael said well michael was
coming up and he was retiring and he was
done
and now lebron comes into the league and
they ask him about jersey why you were
number six why don't you wear number 23
and all this stuff and lebron said
i think we should retire to number 23
nobody should ever wear it again
remember what michael said
michael said the nba is bigger than one
player
he says i appreciate the compliment but
the nba is bigger than me it's a bigger
franchise than i am
it's going to continue what does lebron
do he goes and wears number 23.
right afterwards okay i'm going to work
20. by the way he's changing again for
next year
i'm not disagreeing that you uh i'm not
disagreeing with you i'm just saying
that
that conor gets eyeballs and there's no
one even close that's my only only we'll
see we'll see i don't think i debate
that but we'll see okay
do we have our friend there from cuba i
i need
is he on the phone already or no i don't
have the phone where's the phone
to my left my phone to my oh it's right
here
all right let's see is he on there
already or no
watch that how old is he 41.
oh it's a different guy that i saw david
corral where is david corral
do we know where he's david where are
you based out of
where are you based out of all right i'm
texting them right now
david if you're listening to me where
are you based out of are you
florida-based
where are you based out of um i mean
we're going to read a lot of this stuff
that's going on cuba and then i'll come
to david i like to get two people two
different people's perspective is he the
only one that we have where we have a
couple of them
west palm beach okay sounds good do we
have another one as well
look at the two and i'll come to you
david thank you he's from west palm
beach let me read you what's going on
with cuba let me read you what's going
on with cuba and we'll go from there
uh go to page eight we got a lot i got
three stories to read i don't know if
i'm gonna read all three at the same
time but i got three stories to read
okay so let's go into it so number one
a new york post story cubans take the
streets in anti-in massive
anti-government protests thousands of
cubans took the streets sunday in
protest of the country's food shortages
and high prices
amid the chronovirus pandemic the
anti-government protests
in the capital of havana lasted about
two and a half hours before it was
broken up
when a few protesters tossed
cobblestones at police leading to
several arrests
we are fed up with the cues and
shortages that's why i'm here one
middle-aged protester said the communist
party is suffering from its worst
economic crisis in decades and has
recently seen a surge in corona virus's
case
coronavirus cases cuba president miguel
diaz canal
undermines sunday's demonstrations while
visiting the small town of san antonio
de la
de los banos which has been plagued by
power shortages i'm going to continue
the next story is from the independent
cuba protests spread to miami as
president threatens battles in the
streets by the way i landed
in miami last night okay when i was
in uh what do you call it the miami
airport when this was happening m.i.a
everybody traffic was the worst i've
ever seen
flags everywhere honking the horn you
see it all over the place right
well the miami airport is just outside
of little havana of course 45 minutes
away yeah so
thousands of thousands of miami joined
protests in solidarity with the cuban
people rallying against the government
because of food and vaccines shortages
and rising prices cubans in the
thousands also protested on sunday
against the government of president
communist party we know that the country
is also struggling with the sanctions
imposed by the trump administration
after president barack obama tried to
normalize
relations with the country sunday's
protest was one of the biggest
anti-government demonstrations in memory
the associated press writes and the last
story i'll
read is the following cubans denounced
misery in the biggest protests in
decades
the rallies widely viewed as astonishing
for a country that limits dissent
were set up by economic crisis etc okay
so here's
here's a new york times tweet can you
pull up the new york times tweet pull up
the new york times tweet which to me
it's
very very confused i don't know if you
saw this or not did you see the new york
times
here's a new york times tweet here's a
new york times tweet tell me what you
think about this
shouting freedom and other
anti-government slogans
let me read that to you again shouting
freedom
and other anti-government slogans
hundreds of cubans took the streets and
the cities around the country on sunday
to protest food and medicine shortages
and a remarkable eruption
of discontent not seen in nearly 30
years let me let proper english a middle
eastern english is my fifth language
so i took efl not even esl because esl
is second language efl is fifth language
right okay never even heard of that
i haven't either shouting freedom
and other anti-government slogans yeah
does that mean
the word freedom is a form of an
anti-government slogan yes
is that how i'm reading it you're
reading it english off no you're that is
correct
in new york freedom is an
anti-government
that's what they're saying of course
that's what they're saying yes well the
other thing that they were shouting
for the roof they were saying liberta
libertad have you ever seen scarface
yeah that's what they're shouting
no the only thing and the other the
other thing they were saying is we are
not afraid we are not afraid freedom
freedom freedom yeah but whatever
i'm saying yes the answer is yes now the
only thing open to us
the only thing open to interpretation is
are they referencing
cuba where it's a communist country and
freedom does mean anti-government or is
that the new york times philosophy in
general
because that is not an act every word is
thought out very very clearly through
there okay
but so on what's your point with that
pat what i'm feeling
he's saying the new york times is saying
freedom is anti-government and that
they're going to transpose that same
thought process here
which is what essentially they're doing
yeah i mean new york times is the same
the word freedom is anti-government
anti-cuban government no no no no no
anti-gun
and other anti-government slogans the
word freedom
is an anti-government slogan since when
has the word freedom been a bad word to
use
since when has that been like hey any of
these stuff like
today if you today watch this your
question for you if today
you see somebody with a truck with an
american flag on automatically are they
democrats or republicans
republican why why
they they're more patriotic but why
though
i'm confused of course i've asked myself
that same question why
i get that being democrat is somehow
seen as less patriotic
yeah but what i'm trying to tell you is
democrats are afraid to carry their
flags
because when you drive down like when
you drive down a house if you see an
american flag
most people are going to say that house
is what it's a republican house
why though why are republicans proud to
represent
democrats cannot represent their flag
because why why is that why is it
patriotic to say freedom is good why is
it
why is it such an offensive war now
there's that new york times who's got
the kind of influence they got to say
hey
freedom is an anti-government slogan
what are you talking about
what are we talking about here i escaped
iran to be here
for what for freedom you know when i was
in germany at a refugee camp you know
who was there people from albania
people from yugoslavia yugoslavia
doesn't even exist today
yugoslavia poland czechoslovakia now
it's not even czechoslovakia
czechoslovakia all these other places
countries that were under soviet regime
and we were all there we all had one in
common we were
begging for freedom sure everybody was
afraid to claim their religion everybody
was afraid
to voice their everybody was afraid
everybody wanted this thing called
freedom
and today freedom is an anti-government
slogan wow
you know two weeks ago in the podcast we
were talking about um
cnn celebrating china's 100 year
anniversary of communism
and and this ties in with what i'm going
to ask you right now
um you look at cnn you look at the new
york times they're
you know as donald trump used to say
they're failing right the failing new
york times but cnn's ratings speak for
themselves
you cannot have a 40 dip in your ratings
and not have some sort of
economic disaster with a company they go
hand in hand
yeah so are they being secretly funded
by china
i mean is that where the revenue gap is
coming from from cuba
no no i'm talking about liberal media
outlets i'm just wondering is there
cuba is fundamental just so you know
cuba is funded by china china has
a chokehold on cuba there is a power of
china coming in to use cuba as a
platform to that that
that is already one of their chess moves
that's exactly what they do
let me ask you because do you have two
instead of one i need two
i need somebody in their late thirties
and somebody in their twenties to give
me two perspectives
maybe maybe i'm just not understanding
this okay but in my opinion and i could
be wrong you're gonna probably
teach me something as someone who
basically had their freedom or rights
taken away in iran
shouting freedom liberta or against the
government in cuba
anti-government anti-communist you know
regimes yeah why is that a bad thing i'm
not understanding the
no whether this was the new york times
new york post washington what i'm what
i'm not understanding that why is it a
bad thing
yeah like shouting freedom for while
you're under a communist regime
i don't think it is what i'm saying is a
bad thing the fact that
new york times categorically puts the
word freedom as an anti-government
slogan anti-cuban government they it
said anti-government slogan but they're
talking about cuba it's not it's not
about but
what do you mean they're talking about
cuba it's so there's nothing that's the
answer to all stories about
let me ask you bring that tweet back up
are you sincerely
telling me you don't see messaging in
the title
you don't see any you don't read into it
that's why i asked the question right
for you to inform me well then
i'm thinking shouting freedom and other
government slogans
hundreds of cubans took to the streets
so i'm thinking this is a cuban story
i'm not reading it into it i get it this
is america you know what they could have
done they could have done
they could have done shouting many other
things but saying freedom and other
anti-government slogans
other anti-government slogans what is
wrong with shouting freedom
nothing is nothing but new york times is
calling that an anti-government slogan
it is an anti-government slogan in cuba
you cannot it's okay so in new york
times let me ask you a question let me
ask you a question
is is new york times anti-government or
pro-government
i guess they're pro-government i guess
yes they're pro-government what do you
mean you guess they're pro-government
i don't i don't have like the strong
opinion on new york times i think this
is a story about cuba i'm not reading
into
a whole body but that's the problem but
that's the problem that's why i asked
the questions
that's the problem with the fact that
you don't realize the power
of wordsmithing let me tell you there
was a movie called uh
flash of genius you ever seen a movie
flash of genius it's the story about the
intermittent uh what do you call it
windshield wiper the kid the guy that
invents the intern
intermittent windshield wiper if you've
never seen this you got to watch this
movie okay
he's invents it he goes presents us to
ford
ford steals it from him they say he
didn't come up with it we came up with
it
he shows it to chrysler ford to
everybody they take it
he gets nothing for it he goes against
them
for years loses his marriage loses his
kids
loses everything eventually years later
he gets paid 28 million dollars
and everybody had to officially say that
this man invented invented the
intermittent windshield wiper he
represents himself because he has no
money he's so broke
and he gets up there and he says ford
says
to create the intermittent uh uh what do
you call it a windshield wiper
all you need is four pieces you need
this you need this you need that you
need this
meaning force trying to say it's not a
big deal he didn't invent anything
unique
he says you're right but i got a
question for you
um i'm gonna use a few words tell me if
you've ever used these words in your
vocabulary
you ever use the word success yes
you ever use the word hi yes you ever
use the word happy
you ever use the word the you ever use
the word there
like yeah where you're going with this
he says how come
you never wrote a best-selling book
just like he puts the book up which is
the all-time best-selling book of all
time it sold you know
hundreds of millions of copies how come
you've never written the best-selling
book
all the words in this book are words you
know
but the problem with you is you don't
know how to put the words in the right
order
to become a best seller the author here
did what i did is i know how to put
those four items together that anybody
could have done and i invented it i own
the rights to they need to pep and they
need to tell because you cost me my
marriage
my family my kids they need to say
publicly
there is power in word smithing
new york times has a lot of influence
and they know how to put
words together to manipulate the agenda
they're trying to impose
to the average american voter that
doesn't read into it and they say
freedom anti-government slogan and they
say yeah you know what freedom yeah
people who say freedom people who say
freedom people who say freedom they're
probably republicans
no freedom is why america was is the
greatest nation on the planet today it
could still change
freedom is the reason why america is so
special freedom of speech freedom of
enterprise freedom of assembly freedom
of religion i can go on with all these
different freedoms that they provide you
but now it's an anti-government slogan
let me just say this as a writer
that is 100 part of the new york times
messaging that is what they do
it's subtle but it's consistent and it's
constant they use the word
freedom as an anti-government slogan if
they were doing what you think they were
doing because it's a story of cuba
they should have said shouting freedom
and other phrases in
cuba that might be interpreted as
anti-government
comma go on with it but they didn't do
that so that's the exact
i was like 50 words rather than four
words yeah but there's no limit on tweet
twitter now
um but anyway that's exactly what they
did they made that
they do it all the time yeah let me call
this guy here david i'm calling you here
from cuba let's see what david has to
say on what it is to
have lived in cuba for 15 years david if
you're listening i'm calling you
and the next person i'm calling right
after this is rolando
gonzalez david can you hear us
called him do you want me to put him on
speaker or what do you want me to do
he's on david can you hear me yes i can
hear you
okay david so tell us tell us your
background what you do
what your experience has been with cuba
how many years you lived there give us a
little bit about your background 30
seconds hey patrick first of all thank
you thank you for having me
i came to this country when i was 18
years old that was uh six years ago
i came by myself no family only couple
friends in here
i've been listening to you for a long
time i started my business
uh listening to you so i love this
country and one of the reasons i love
this country
is uh because you have at least two
sites and that's what people don't
understand about cuba
on the news right now they're saying
that we are protesting against
kobe down against food nothing like that
in response to island
what what are they saying about that is
because the news over here they don't
want to discuss against the socialists
and the only reason that we are
protesting in q1 is because the
communist regime
nothing else we have been for 62 years
we have no food
we have no liberty nothing so right now
we're tired of all that
and i'm so i'm sorry for my english
david tell me are you in communication
with your family in cuba right now
yeah so what they did yesterday after
the first day of everything go to the
street they shut down the internet
so right now they got our entire country
and shut down so the only way that we
can
uh spoke with them is paying uh paying
money over here i'm making them
pay money over there but they cannot
share anything that is happening right
now
so when my mom 20 uh 20 minutes ago much
better they got like on the
they got on like on the on the smaller
towns they got on them on the center of
the town yeah got the president
on the speaker shouting like like
everything is okay
this is a fall of the united states
because embargo there is no embargo
because they still have yes they are
millionaires and the people from cuba
are hungry
and they are ripping the people from
united states here because we have to
send
anything to to to help our moms and now
or family in cuba
like for example patrick my brother is a
doctor he
he used to make 40 dollars in cuba a
month that's a much higher salary how
much money
for 40 dollars a month wait let me get
this straight your brother's a doctor he
made 40 dollars a month is the highest
salary in cuba as a doctor
and used to put that in perspective
right now a tylenol
like 10 pillars for headaches it's a
hundred dollars in cuba
wow it's a hundred dollars so think alan
think about that
when when you guys talk about social
insight companies and
the left wing and i'm saying this i
really like you and it's really good to
have democrat friends
because i have democrat friends and all
that's good that you guys are good
because we we need two sides
you know sometimes we are too over
yourself and you it's good to have two
sides
but that's that the side that is only
this country the democrats the main guys
they're all corrupt because they they
don't even want to talk about cuba right
now
because a lot of q a voted for by them
because the same reason
that you say because you don't like
trump and we don't like trump either
but we know that this was going to
happen if we have trump right now in
business even though that we don't like
it
he was going to put a better position
against cuba
and the reason that biter is not taking
that position is because they are trying
to protect the energy and that like the
socialist agenda that they get
so uh my brother my brother was a doctor
he made forty dollars in cuba so he had
to go
uh work fights seven days a week and
after he finished
saving lives with the motorcycle that he
bought making a bakery in our home so he
he he had to go to the doctor uh save
life and then come back
and spend four or five hours of making
like a small uh bakery
to sell we help my mom help and
everybody help them that's that's the
only
way that you can survive in cuba let me
let me ask you a question david
when trump announced the sanctions nine
months ago that he put on cuba where no
american person can stay on a
a property in cuba i believe that's a
cuban owned property
when he put those sanctions to hurt the
economy of cuba to
hopefully have a revolution where the
people would go up against the
government
how did the people in cuba feel about
trump's sanctions he posed against cuba
patrick 95 percent of cuba know that
that is good
because they even without that sanctions
they still having bad
thrones for 62 years there is nothing
new for 62 years
we have to send money from here to the
western union let's say
so what they do is they take your
dollars the dollar that i make
they keep it and then they give you some
monopoly uh dollars to the to the people
so right now instead of making if i send
hundred dollars on cuba right now
they only give it like 80. on paper that
don't
work for nothing so everybody in q1
don't let like the news from here
letting you otherwise everybody in q1
knows that we have to be harder without
with the deterioration
because even though these sanctions
don't affect enough in the country
they only affect the people on uh on
power
they got they got uh they got uh they
got jobs on ibiza right now
castro's sons castro's daughter
everybody is fleeing out
raul castro they he took a a plane
yesterday to venezuela
so i've been talking i've been texting
to your program like for
four months uh four uh four weeks ago
patrick because i know that you do a lot
of interviews for everybody i've been
following for a lot of years
and i hope in the future you can do
something about this the main reason
that we got this socialist influence on
the united states right now
is cuba cuba is behind venezuela
military on cuba
is ruining venezuela well first of all
david thank you so much for
uh being uh giving us your perspective
of where you're at uh and appreciate you
listening to this completely different
perspective on what you said on what's
going on with cuba
uh once again thank you for your time
david appreciate you and padre
hello yeah i'm listening go ahead uh
yeah just wanna uh
shout out to my people in san nicolas
party they they came out to the street
yesterday but there are smaller towns
people in havana come away big cities
still out
and for my people here in the united
states i want to let you know this is
what happened
when you let people from the government
take your guns this is what happened
with the government
it's too big all these stimulus shake
that's what they do they give you free
money now
and then when they take it apart from
you then you're 15 years from now you
have nothing
so you cannot defend yourself and
patrick for the people that are saying
that
this is a civil war this is not civil
war because we don't have guns they are
killing my people in the town
my people have nothing no not even uh
not even
alcohol bars with fire they got nothing
and they they kill a kid yesterday 13
years old the police get a kid
and uh they shoot somebody on the face
right next to my town
so they are killing my people don't let
the news saying otherwise
this is like hong kong like everybody
say they are trying to say something
different now
my people is on the street we don't have
guns we are trying to take the gun from
the police but we can't we don't have
guns
they got tanks they got everybody
everybody on the united states right now
is asking for intervention military in
cuba
we don't care what happened next we just
don't want the dictatorship there
for for all that i care i can go and
take over
you and make you on the next puerto rico
even if you want to stay even his
illuminati want to send
tell the factory and make everybody on
cool and where work for the meaningful
salary
they can do that we kill us are a part
of that we don't we don't care about the
the the the company is the social image
that's why everybody in cuba is voting
for trump
because something something different
what's your every every every people
here ask oh what cuban people vote for
trump because this situation
every immigrant that is right here in
this country right now we have been
running from a left government
here from the left oh my gosh
it's tough to debate that now this is
firsthand david once again appreciate
you man thank you so much have a good
one
appreciate it anytime what a perspective
what a perspective don't you think we
really
have to follow what our reaction as a
country is in cuba
other than saying we're monitoring it i
mean don't we have to step in and help
these people at some point
not militarily though the perspective
that the media gives you
they tell you the reason why this is
happening
is because of coronavirus jen what's up
what's her name
she said it's because we need to send
them more vaccine shots that's why
they're protesting they're not
protesting backs anybody
this is not a vaccine protest this is
not a covet protest this is their sick
and tired of
a doctor making 40 bucks a month and
tylenol cost
a hundred dollars for 10 pills you
kidding me and you heard what he said
about the gun thing
where police killed the 13 year old
yesterday in the city and the town right
next to the town he was uh
living it completely different
perspective i'm going to call the next
person here
rolando gonzalez is a mechanic
mechanical engineer from cuba
moved at 26 years old and has lived here
four lived in florida for the last 14
years so 40 years old 26 years in cuba
let's see what perspective he's got for
us two things foreign i mean how
horrific is that for everybody they
can't even communicate and they took
their guns so forget about having a coup
how do you communicate they haven't had
guns
rolando how are you hi davey
how you doing i'm doing fine i'm
appreciated you take this time any time
so give us perspective what do you think
about what's going on and if you're
communicating with your family in cuba
what do they tell you that telling you
that's happening over there that the
media is not telling us
first than anything i want to say thank
you to you guys
tom adams padre kai everyone's there
for you know help me to tell the war
what is happening in cuba
shout out to david he he explained a lot
i think right now we are on big problems
i
i've been in communication with my
family yesterday night they was able to
use
vpn to get access to whatsapp
and they don't know i'm from a small
town they don't know anything about
what's happening
around there i begin to send them
pictures to them
and i helping them to put the other cell
phones that they got to vpn
also yeah so they can be able to see
that the big problem is we don't have
internet they don't have communication
in between
they chop down the light they're playing
something now they call point kasich
which is like taking out the
communication take the towns
they mobilize regular people to fight on
different towns let's say if you are
from
miami they take you from miami to five
to four lord of the people
and then they bring people from fort
lauderdale to find miami
why are they doing it what's the reason
for doing that well they say
they say in cuba you have to go to
military service it's obligatory right
so they prepare you for that right so
what they're doing is they say oh these
people are from you know
is a people that got influenced from the
united states so let's gonna put it
you know let's gonna bring us to what we
need or social
[ __ ] you know yeah and there is
communication between both way
the problem is you are from a small town
you don't know anything what is
happening
on the town next to you and they take
you there when they put you there you
don't know what you're fighting for
you know you were training to fight you
know an enemy from outside of the
country not to your own people
that's what they're doing um i sent kai
i sent kai on the text
uh a picture how they are like two two
policemen
with a young kid that certain year old
that they kill
they got i sent you another video there
also
um you can put it after and second forty
you can see how like six eight people
beating
to each other it's crazy what the police
is doing is
totally wrong let me ask you a question
who's creating this division
is there division being created the
government is the government
so how are those how are they pinning
people against each other what's their
method of pinning people against each
other
okay so they go to your home says okay
we got an intervention
and we need your be a part of this one
because you're part of the reserve
right yep they take you they put you in
another town yeah you don't have any
news
you don't know anything like the same
you was talking about the
that news there that was totally run
it's the same with cnn
yet to deny what's what say what is this
they're they're getting the information
so
wrong they don't get the right
information everything that david said
before was right
he was totally right they're
manipulating the informations going in
and out
and here the left is doing the same let
me let me ask you this other question
when you are somebody that lived in cuba
for 26 years you've been here for
14 years you're 40 years old i'm
assuming you got why you got a family
right you're a family man you're saying
yes sir
okay yes how do you see what's happened
in america do you see any similar trends
with what's happening here
with what happened in cuba do you see
any similar trends
oh definitely definitely i would say
something
pretty shout out to ben shapiro yet
today he says something pretty good
let's take the people who doesn't love
america send them to cuba
and let's bring the people who love who
love freedom
bring him here yeah to do that that's
going to be
absolutely impossible because aoc will
have a very hard time selling her 20
sweaters for 60 dollars in cuba because
even a doctor couldn't afford to buy her
sweater in cuba
anyways thank you hold on one question
yeah go for it
sure what's your name again buddy
rolando rolando
yes sir other than the covid right
obviously that's change the world what's
different now
between five years ago 10 years ago 20
years ago socialism communism castro
they've been there
what's different now other than covet
okay first you back
like let's say a year ago you got two
two currencies there
you can buy a list with that two
currencies now
you get paid on cuban money but you
cannot buy on cuban money you have to
buy
with dollars then they say no we don't
want dollars
we want euros now so basically they're
paying you and cuban money but you
cannot go
and and buy let's say a beer or just
like cigarettes so you're saying what
you're saying the one thing that has
changed is the
currency that's accepted well
again this is just because they want the
people from the outside
pay their their things you know let's
say if i send now
money to my family yeah they can
let's say i put it here a hundred a
hundred and thirty dollars
my family get a hundred dollars but they
don't get a hundred dollars they get it
in cuba
david said by the way they can't they
cannot go to the
they cannot go to their stores and buy
food we're taxing them so
let me ask you a question so if you wire
money from here if you send money from
your western union to your family in
cuba no no no no black market blood
market
you don't do westwood martin that's what
he's saying it's you don't do well you
don't do
uh what's your union over no they they
go out of the country
they go out of the country so it's
basically if you go through the
government you put like 130 here you
probably get like 80 there
but always they don't have money
who is covering the story on media like
if you were to say a a certain
podcast a certain news station a certain
newspaper that's covering the accurate
stories of what's going on in cuba who
would you say
okay okay um is a
it's a radio guy from miami that make an
interview to jotul which is a musician
from
from cuba who live in miami they're
covering the the history pretty good
there what's his name what's his name
is from the group or richas yeah can you
write that down
let's write that down y-o-u-t-e-l
y-o-u-t-e-l
we're trying to get a hold on you town
yeah i'm sorry well
y-o-t-u-e-l
y-o-t-u-e-l you're 12. yeah you're 12.
these are people these people are
these people are calling the history
pretty good um
i will i would suggest to go to facebook
and look for people who are posting
videos you know
and all the news here and saying oh this
protest was just on sunday
it wasn't just a sunday was sunday
monday
and still doing today again what's that
but we are
getting the videos pretty late ricky
always calls trash about jorge ramos
what are your thoughts on jorge ramos i
i don't like it
i don't see any i honestly i don't see
any lighting um
media at all you don't see any what you
don't see anyone oh you mean for
univision
yeah like latinos latinos latinos media
no
no univision no telemundo let me ask you
a question why are so many latinos in
america
not supportive of what you stand for why
are so many latinos and media who
escaped
socialism who escaped the the
experiences they had
why are they not supporting you know
and i'm not talking about everybody
there's a lot of people that are there's
a lot of people in media that'll say
it's not fair what's going on and by the
way that that could be on the left and
the right you heard what
rubio said yesterday you heard what the
mayor of miami suarez said yesterday
he was out there protesting he was out
there representing the people on sunday
and now this is not negotiable yeah this
is not negotiable why are so many people
in media
just kind of like oh you know it's it's
it's kovit it's vaccine
because because first thing is patrick
language is a huge barrier and a lot of
people is coming from cuba
they don't they don't speak english even
my english is very bad but i can
understand everything
people doesn't doesn't speak english so
the only way that they have to see
is whatever they see on the media that's
universal that's a very powerful point
i always say guys i i love i know what
you're doing i follow you guys and i
think it's pretty good
the way that you're doing honestly i
open google every morning
read the news and my others my the other
way that i do is just go to your podcast
well that's that's great to hear and we
appreciate the support rolando thank you
so much for giving us perspective on how
things are going right now in cuba
uh and uh we wish you and your family
not about the very best man appreciate
you thank you
thank you guys how interesting is that
you're hearing about you know what's
crazy
somebody commented they said now has
this become a right-wing podcast
is what somebody said no not at all what
part of what we just did
do we do we know who rolando is i've i
don't know i've never met this guy do i
know who david is i've never met david
brandon
we're getting perspective of what
they're saying but
because the story and the narrative
they're saying doesn't
match what telemundo what univision and
what cnn and what msnbc what some others
are saying
this is automatically a right wing
versus a group of people that are
independent thinkers
yes you may be a little bit more center
left yes i may be a little bit more
center right yes you may be a little bit
whatever different
feelings that we have but automatically
look where identity politics goes you
automatically go that's what this person
is that's what that person so let me
just say something yeah
i'm born and raised in miami i've grown
up with cubans
all like born and raised in miami yeah i
grew up i
lived up until moving up to boca a mile
outside a little havana i
tons of cuban friends i know the mayor
very well i have
tons of cuban friends and this is
nothing new meaning they've been
they came here in the late 70s early 80s
obviously you know people came here
in the 1950s after castro but people i
know have been here for a long time
this is nothing new in regards to we've
been we've known what socialism and
communism has done to cuba
and venezuela for years what i think is
happening now
where the covid thing is is
one of the things that cuba gets
recognized for is their socialized
medicine and socialized education
and that is clearly falling apart right
now covet has exacerbated the problems
that exist in communism
now there's food shortages obviously
they turned off the internet
social uh unrest high food prices
collapsing infrastructure kai i actually
went to cuba i don't know if we want to
pull this up right now
but this is nothing new we've i've
miamians have been talking trash about
cuba
forever so here's a good little story
this is it's a nice facade
of what's going on they got the nice
cars basically from the 1950s
it looks great and this is the town
center cali we can just keep going
and but then you start driving around
when you're in these cars and you see
the actual
infrastructure so i went to cuba 2014 i
want to say
under the obama administration but
basically when you peel back
from you know here's a guy's it was our
it was our
there's our driver seemed like a happy
guy but it seems nice it seems
um what's a word that you know it's like
a throwback almost
but then when you actually get in the
car and start driving around cuba here's
what we saw
raising that volume
all right so we're taking a tour in one
you know a 1960 thunderbird
and then we drive past this street right
here people live there
people live there that's where people
live and here's what used to be a
gorgeous building
and then just crumbling infrastructure
and that was my biggest takeaway
from being in cuba because we were there
for 48 hours we had a good time you know
12 miami dudes having a nice time in
cuba uh for my friend keith's bachelor
party
but this is my biggest takeaway what's
your point here's my point
the facade of communism looks great on
the outside
the nice nice uh yeah you know uh
capital
looks good you're in these nice cars
then you start driving into the
neighborhoods
my biggest takeaway is you see all these
buildings that are
gorgeous architecture gorgeous and then
just crumbling
crumbling from the inside so we stayed
in a nice hotel we're thinking oh this
looks pretty cool
no big deal is it's nice here and then
you start driving the streets and you
start seeing the people that are going
on there and the crumbling
infrastructure
and then you realize oh okay that's
what's going on behind the scenes
here that building is an example i'll
say this my heart goes out to every
cuban that's living in cuba right now
when you
when you call your revolt in what you're
doing you're uprising
misery you can understand what the
conditions are and the government only
makes it worse and worse and worse for
them taking their electricity taking
their internet so
prayers for you guys and i'm hoping some
people with money here in the united
states some influential cubans can do
something i don't know what
he's trying to tell you is the fact that
they're not even letting money get in
there because they're
taxing the money that's going into the
system so they're not even letting that
take place
anyway so look more power to orlando and
david for giving perspective now you
kind of have an idea from people that
live there and are saying what is
currently taking place when they're
communicating
it's even hard for them to communicate
with the people there yesterday aoc go
to aoc's twitter account i don't know if
she's already twitted 40 other things
we're not going to be able to find it
but just go on twitter type in aoc go to
her uh yeah go straight to her
uh let's see what we got here keep going
up keep going up keep going up keep
going up there and martial
okay here's here's the message that you
have uh go go up one go up one
so she said this martin luther king was
murdered in front of congresswoman
today's gop we are
gutting the very voting rights act king
worked for you don't want to believe
something
does it go up one more like mind if i
click on that one right there the bottom
one the one that says whites it must be
frankly said okay go
up she says something else on the bottom
keep going right there
the quote of king is not from an early
work it is from one of his last words
where do we go from here chaos or
community
uh if all sorts of folks who claim what
mlk would do actually studies at work
they would understand he was a radical
and an anti-capitalist too you know
what's crazy
she says that now go to my twitter
account go to my twitter account and i
retweeted her
and i had my thoughts to say about this
year okay
go up and let me see where it's at there
you go while the world is witnessing the
people of cuba protest against socialism
and communism you trash capitalism
terrible timing to bash capitalism
especially when your ultimate capital is
using your platform to sell 20
sweaters for 60 right so the point is
she has a platform to trash capitalism
young innocent naive people who have
never lived in cuba who have never
lived in iran who have never lived in a
communistic regime before
look at that and say oh my gosh she
knows what she's talking about words
have a lot of power and today these
words are influencing the younger
audience to say
capitalism sucks rich people suck
socialism is the way to go right that's
the direction we want to kind of
pitch america to go the good news is
that we're starting to see people like
ashton kutcher mcconaughey some of these
other guys just saying i don't know if
that's the direction we want to go
hopefully those people will rise up more
and
they'll push back some of these
initiatives i there's gonna come a time
next 10 or 20 years when she's going to
run for president and i've already told
you what my belief system is what
percentage it is
the day she becomes a president folks be
ready this is all i'm going to tell you
the day she becomes a president she is
going
if you fast forward between now and 20
years from now how many followers you
think aoc is going to have in 20 years
it's right now she's got 12 and a half
million
what do you think she's going to have in
10 years 50 million what are you talking
about
in 10 years how many followers do you
think she'll have 150 probably
she's probably going to be 150 million
follower person
passing agenda like this what do you
think is going to be the chance of a
running
very very high brace for impact
i had one of my employees i was speaking
to him i said so uh uh
house family house kids how's this he
says you know what my wife and i made
one decision what's that
we're not gonna have kids so why not i
said to be honest with you we talked to
the family about this
this is a conservative family i said why
are you not having kids he says
pat with everything that's going on
today why have kids
when we know whatever we do to raise the
kids the school the media everybody's
trying to shape their way of thinking
that we can't win that battle
did you see the video that i said i
don't know by the way i think that's a
horrible perspective
it's not i don't know who said that but
it's it's not i think that's a i think
but
that's the decision a couple have yeah
that's what i don't know who said it i
don't know why they said it
is a i think that's a cop-out first of
all i'm having four kids you think i'm
sitting there agreeing with the guy what
i'm trying to tell you is the fact that
people are afraid of having kids
because they're worried about how
dangerous it is right now like
if if right now if right now you know in
the next 10 or 20 years a person like
aoc is going to be president you excited
about it
no i wouldn't be excited about it but
that wouldn't prevent me from having
kids
not saying that's like a doomsday
scenario he's like a prepper whoever
that is is like a prepper
not you but there are a lot of people
who are educated smart people
who are worried about what the future
looks like the only reason somebody's
not having kids today is because they're
worried about the next 10 20 30 years
look i get the guy's perspective i mean
look yesterday
i'm flying here and uh you know i get
married i don't get it i guess
a week ago my daughter asked me my
daughter ivana asked hey dad you think
we're gonna have to wear masks next year
at school i said no way
look at california's open right now it
feels normal everything's great there's
no way yesterday
they announced mass are mandatory and
then they did it about phase later
i think and they said that every school
district's gonna be able to make that
decision i was so depressed when i heard
that
i mean they're coming after these kids
again they've already robbed a year and
a half of their life
literally they've taken it from that the
kids are going to get it back yeah well
of course
they are going back to school they are
going back to school and they were not
in school like your kids were not in
school at all last year in california
they were they didn't go back to school
until april and then it was like one or
two hours a day one or two days a week
but at least for right now i know school
doesn't start till august september yeah
the plan is they're going back full time
but
they better not be wearing mass that's
all i can say but but california can
impose that on them if they wanted to
it's that simple california can't say
you know they're going to be
uh not wearing mask or wearing masks
having to do that and they have nothing
to say you can't say nothing
about that at all larry kudlow has a
story that came out let's go to page
eight here's what he had to say larry
kudlow is with uh fox business
he said we are fighting for the souls of
america for the soul of america we are
fighting for this very soul of this
great country and there's no better way
to
do it than to compare the ultra blue
state of california versus the ultra red
state of florida
california had some of the hardest
coveted lockdown measures while florida
was among one of the first
states to reopen way back in may of
2020.
california's economy has a 7.9
unemployment rate florida is below 5
percent california has a 13.3 percent
top income tax rate florida does not
have an income tax california has
amongst
the biggest homeless population in the
country though it has only 12 percent of
america's population
california has one quarter of america's
homeless let me read that one more time
even though california only has 12
percent of america's population
california has a quarter
25 percent of america's homeless florida
is america's
free estate according to cato institute
survey number one in fiscal freedom
number one in educational freedom
cato dubs california one of the least
free states
and flat out dubs it the most croniest
state in the union
new york post columnist kylie smith says
again
the most croniest state in the union
cronius means
people who are able to buy politicians
in that state to get any agenda they
want to get past it
adam your big larry kudlow guy what do
you think about what he has to say about
this yeah i actually
you know he's on fox business he was um
at one point for a brief stint for like
less than a year
trump's economic advisor is on his
council
look uh there you you talked about being
a wordsmith
earlier about the new york times uh
larry carlo did some word smithing here
especially smith
can i you call stats wordsmithing can i
say my point
but but you call it what you got
smithing i'm asking you a question
did i get can i say my point you usually
ask me what's my point
yeah i'm about to get to my point i'm
sorry i'm talking about the stats
tell me tell me here's my note since you
so rudely interrupted so tell us
i said he's right but it's overdramatic
as an example here's my problem with him
yeah the ultra red
state of florida are you willing to say
that florida is ultra rare
by the way today texas isn't even ultra
rare hear me out today
today many people would say florida's
more red than texas today
many people would say florida and texas
has have switched in the last 18 months
i don't agree with that however i don't
know he may have been
saying the government is ultra red well
but let's hear your broader points
i think look as someone who has lived in
florida's all life i think you would be
willing to say
desantis has done a good job here marco
rubio little marco rubio rick scott
those are both
senators republican senators i'm just
taking your notes buddy
alabama west virginia mississippi states
that no one's
trying to live in by the way when you
move valuetainment you didn't think well
what's going on in west virginia this
month
that didn't happen i definitely didn't
think california new york either okay
yeah
exactly and the whole reason look
the numbers are true i'm not debating
that my whole thing was he's right but
it's dramatic
it's a dramatic effect this is
wordsmithing here yeah the ultra red
state of florida no this is as purple as
it gets it's voted
uh clinton it's voted obama it's voted
trump it's voted by
like it goes either way however i think
larry kudlow has a major point here
i'm in florida i'm thankful for living
in florida it's the free estate in the
god damn union
respect now let's talk to a socialist
over here from california
okay go back to your point yeah worth
smithing stats
i'm saying i didn't i didn't say
anything about the stats
i agree with the stats i said he's right
and he's true
he's just over dramatic okay what the
over dramatic part is
ultra red state which i disagree with
exactly that's my point
but the stats tell a very and i agree
with you
i'm not i'm not questioning this right
the stats tell you exactly
thank you to live in florida and not
california let's talk
you know do you know how many people
i've brought over here yeah
and they've stayed here for a week let's
just say okay
i went to a restaurant the other day
whatever it's called the blue moon
something something where it's right
across
for a lot it's actually a real nice
restaurant i don't know what it's called
a nice restaurant you go pay
lunch as like you know uh uh he pays
blue martini i don't know what it's
called nice restaurant on the water
so i'm there i'm leaving uh uh and i'm
getting the valet this
65 year old lady is outside with a mask
on
and she says i cannot believe the level
of irresponsibility
of these people in florida how do you
guys dare
walk around without a mask on and dylan
and tico and santa are right next to me
right
and my dad next to me i'm like really i
said man i'm so sorry you feel that way
where are you from i'm from california
we are responsible that
really yeah what part of california what
do you know about california
i may know a little bit about yeah where
are you from mission viejo do you know
where that's at yeah i lived in
california 24 years in socal
okay i see you know what i've noticed
about californians she said what
i said i've noticed in californians
whether you're left or right you're
miserable today
why because the ones who are on the left
who believe everybody should wear a mask
they think everybody's an idiot who
doesn't wear a mask and they're so
bitter
and the ones on the right are so bitter
today because they don't want to be
forced to wear a mask
california has become bitter county and
there's a lot of people that are bitter
like yourself
and nobody can make anybody happy in
california that's why a lot of people
men from your state are coming to states
like texas and florida
whatever she walked around what are the
odds that she ran into you
in the valet line come on you can so
anyways what are your thoughts my
thoughts are hey you know i'm going to
take the positive spin here 12
of the population lives in california we
have 25 of the homeless population we're
over achievers
i mean we're amazing you know here's the
thing at what point do people with
common sense and intelligence understand
that um it doesn't have to continue to
be this way
there are alternatives and it starts
with government and and you know what we
have the big election coming up here
i don't know if we have a shot or not
but it's easy to take shots at
california right now because we deserve
it and you don't see a lot of hope
um he's also very good at getting the
attention he he said that he sees
florida and south florida replacing wall
street i just don't see that happening
do you i mean could you activate
actually it would take
this state state like not state as a
state of texas
it would take the state the current
state of economy in new york to stay
like this for a decade
if it does it can happen but if it
changes if california and new york
change within the next 18 months let's
just say larry elder announced yesterday
he's run for governor for california i
don't know if you heard that or not
last night larry you know larry elders
who helped flip i think uh
conservative yeah black conservative he
announced yesterday he's running for
governor of the state of california
david rubin david rubin david
and larry elders got a big following in
the state of
california he's got a big following
period he's obviously loved and hated
because he's hated
he's got a lot of people that can't
stand what he stands for because he's a
conservative in the city of california
california is right now getting a lot of
people that are going to be running if
the politics in california new york
changes there's no way that's going to
be happening to florida
but if california and new york stay like
this for another decade
he's absolutely right florida will be
the next wall street
well i actually went down and did an
episode for valuetainment economics at
an event called
roi miami and the whole theme was is
miami becoming the next
silicon valley yeah and basically all
these tech entrepreneurs
wall street type silicon valley types
investors
were you know coming to south florida as
their new haven to get away from what
was going on in california
it's ironic because there's another
story here about the global venture
funding
basically saying you know what the next
silicon valley is silicon valley
it's basically saying sorry austin sorry
miami but funding for companies in the
bay area jumped
93 in 2020 which gave silicon valley its
second consecutive
20 billion dollar quarter it's still by
far
the largest tech hub so 10 years from
now
maybe but right now silicon valley is
still the silicon valley
all right so let's talk about the last
story here we'll wrap up i really want
to touch that joke of its story but but
kai
you know to touch that story we're not
going to listen
i want to touch it i want to touch it so
bad you have no idea i'm just going to
give the business insider title
is all i'm going to say this is all
about i don't know pat i'm not reading
it's a business insider which is a
left-leaning newspaper
website they're left-wing please of
course there are no time
says he might refuse to be vaccinated
against the coronavirus because the
world
number one is opposed to vaccinations
that's the title of the business insider
story
if you haven't read it i suggest you go
read it having said that
let's skip the story to the next story
let's talk about what our friend
adam's best friend donald trump had to
say about facebook and twitter
he recently decided to sue those guys
this is a reuters story
trump sues facebook twitter and google
claiming censorship former u.s president
donald trump on wednesday five lawsuit
against those guys
as well as their chief executives
alleging their unlawfully silenced
conservative viewpoints a lawsuit filed
in the u.s district
court of miami allegedly
california-based social media platform
violated the right to freedom of speech
guaranteed by the first amendment u.s
constitution trump is seeking
class action status for the lawsuit
meaning the world they
he would represent the interests of
other users of twitter facebook google
youtube who allege they have been
unfairly silenced he filed three
lawsuits
making similar allegations one against
facebook mark zuckerberg one against
twitter jack dorsey and one against
google
sandor sundar okay thoughts
on this lawsuit i'm going to shock you
let's hear it but actually i'm good with
this i hope
he i'm glad you are yeah i mean because
we're talking about this before you
support this
meaning if there's anything that i'm not
a fan of that's the big tech
overreach that's happening in this
country right now conservative voices
they're they're you know running off to
platforms like parlor and other
platforms that are happening right now
i'd like to see where this goes
you know at the same time you know these
private companies are going to be able
to say look we can have we could do what
we want
i know trump has not been a fan of
section 230 either is biden
section 230 is the thing that's big up
for debate uh but i'd like to see where
this goes from here
however here's my prediction i know you
talked about you don't want trump to run
you think he's gonna run i'm gonna say i
think trump is 1000 running in 2024
but i actually do not think he has a
chance unless he actually wins this
lawsuit and can get on these platforms
without twitter without facebook without
youtube without all that stuff
he doesn't have a chance way too early
to say he doesn't have a chance there's
so many things i can change in this
country
um my biggest takeaway from this is how
he claims that facebook
was in cahoots essentially with the
centers for disease control
and fauci and to advance the only the
narrative that the defendants and dr
fauci subscribe i think you mean fousey
yeah fousey
by the way he's 80 years old by the way
and the highest paid government employee
um so there you go i want to watch that
because
now what are you hearing all you're
hearing about is the delta variant
yesterday we already mentioned about the
mass going back on the kids i'm worried
about where things are going with kovid
because they've used it in the past
they're going to weaponize it again
and i'm scared what do you think pat i
think you know the trump has sued
1900 people prior to him running for
president he's used to being litigious
and soon people
what that means out of his 1900 lawsuits
like is he going to win or make any kind
of a head wave i don't know i don't know
if anything's going to take place over
there
there's too many people that would love
for him
to not have the freedom to voice his
opinion on facebook twitter and youtube
and those people are on the left
now somehow someway i will give you
timing
and i'll give you a prediction here you
ready i'm gonna give you the craziest
prediction here and i think i'm gonna be
right
when did pfizer announce that their
vaccine is ready it's like right after
the election two days after the election
you know when trump's going to be free
to have facebook twitter and youtube
back
a day after election midterms not
midterms
2024. he will be back on facebook
twitter and youtube
in december of 2024. that is my
prediction and i'm sticking to it
and the people of power no timing
they've done a great job with us
strategically
manipulative dark dirty but they're
going to play that card and they're
going to say yes let's drag out this
lawsuit
mr trump you won but december 2024 by
that time you're 78 which means for you
to run at 82
will not happen that means we will never
get a second term
with the president you don't think that
they're cunning and conniving
of course yeah so that's my prediction
anyways folks we are back again this
thursday
uh podcast if you enjoy the podcast give
us a sup we are again 33 000 subs so if
you enjoyed today put a thumbs up
and thanks to ronaldo and david for
their perspective on cuba
hopefully a lot of progress will be
happening there stay tuned to thursday
because you said you have a big
announcement
friday okay this announcement's going to
be made and it'll be it'll be a topic of
discussion we'll be talking about this a
lot we're all excited to hear from
you it's going to cost me a lot of money
but i'm willing to put my money where my
mouth is because i put my
uh because i think this is something
that's necessary for america
great show today guys yes fantastic
really enjoyed it thanks everybody take
care
you